everyone and welcome to GameSpot's III
coverage 2015 it is day to the show and
I'm very excited to be joined by Kurt
Marga now who is the lead game designer
on uncharted 4 I swapped for this I've
swapped for this away because I'm so
excited about joining for um so good we
were just talking about a little bit a
very big III for you guys what's the
reaction been like to the gameplay ah
yeah it's it's been great we always
loved e3's always it's my favorite time
of year it's better than Christmas for
me we finally get to show we've been
working on these damn this demo for many
months and finally getting to show it to
the world I go in the press conference
seeing you know the reaction from the
crowd is really the the most like
visceral so close as you get in the
video game world to really like being a
rock star or whatever but just it's the
live performance of it and Bruce playing
live on stage it's it is it is kind of a
performance and yeah that's great i love
it and you kind of you guys kind of had
like the big encore i guess because
sony's press conference had so many big
and answer and then you guys were right
at the end yeah showing off live
gameplay so I mean how did you pick that
area because you kind of adding a lot
into uncharted for your kind of making
it bigger than ever before how did you
choose that area to show off well we
started off and first gameplay we show
was the PSX demo back in December and
that was kind of want to make sure that
we hope the first thing we showed was
like core gameplay just the new combat
bigger wider spaces that I'm chart is
all about flow and movement and linking
all your moves together and then for
this e3 we wanted to make sure that we
can still bring a set piece that we it's
still the fun pulp adventure that
everyone loves about uncharted and
trying to just deliver that in like the
most bombastic way possible because I
think with them the first reveal trailer
everyone was not concerned but maybe
they thought uncharted was kind of
tonally was gonna be a bit darker that
the subtitles obviously a thief's end I
had that lovely blue and dark color
palette and then this III demo it kind
of reminded us what I've charted what
exactly I totally the intention like
this Madagascar city is so colorful like
our art directors just
filling the world with color and singing
up on the stage and all its like the
video calibration on the monitor was
really good we're very like particular
about that kind of stuff and how the
game looks on different screens but yeah
it looked amazing yeah so let's talk a
little bit about some of the new
additions so in the PSX demo you saw
that Nate when he's climbing he seems
out like a lot more freedom it's not
just following the Golden Path anymore
uh when it comes to combat it seems
there's a ton more ways to take a look
at this yeah I mean a big thing for us
is like more choice of the player bigger
spaces multiple paths use on the PSX
demo it's like we just give you an
environment to kind of play around in
climb up we give you a goal and kind of
head towards it same thing in the in the
demo we showed at the press conference
we kind of give you a goal and we give
you mechanics in this case driving for a
first time yeah and giving you multiple
routes and kind of letting you find your
way down to sams tower so it's it's all
all the little roads you see all the
paths you can choose to go in our are
all viable options yeah I mean that must
be is that not more fun to design full
because you're kind of fun yeah is the
word to say very hard yeah it's it's
tricky area in the Jeep this sequence
especially I can't wait for people to
play it in the real game because it's uh
it's pretty awesome so we can see him at
me is nice driving to the first time he
could drive stick he does well I am very
proud that innate drive stick I'm a big
car guy myself I've always burn I dog to
have vehicles uncharted course thinks
gonna drive stick so it's not like I
mean there must be some of these
obviously scripted because I mean that
car coming out right there and I'm this
yeah there's like we have entire crowd
systems for you know crowd getting out
of the way we have a special AI we wrote
specifically for this truck to kind of
hunt you through these corridors so it's
all you know as systemic as we possibly
can make it oh wow okay I don't like
let's talk a little bit because you go
more open worlds I mean has it been kind
of tricky because you have to have so
much more to fill or is it been more of
a like a fun challenge I mean I open
world isn't word I would use I would say
it's we're opening it up more for the
player for sure we for uncharted though
it's all about the pacing so we have to
be very cautious when we do open it up
that that it maintains the pacing of the
story so in this case it's like yeah but
this is an action this is a set-piece
moment so it's gonna be a directed
experience what we're giving you as much
freedom as we possibly can within that
so I mean one thing we haven't really
seen much of which I'm kind of desperate
to find out more details about is the
story so we know obviously the Troy
Baker's involved it's Nate's wayward
brother Sam Sully's park i'm hoping
Alana's mark i hope for Chloe I mean are
you guys gonna be releasing any more
details or you know are you gonna keep
us in suspense uh we'll keep you in
suspense a little bit but well yeah Nate
has a brother he's been away for they've
been separated for 15 years and kind of
the theme of the game is family and and
Nate gets kind of pulled back in he's
cell down with Elena and he gets pulled
back in by his brother comes back into
his life and he's got it he needs his
help so we're kind of we're seeing a
little bit here we're getting to Sam are
helping out and when the extended demo
continues you'll see a little bit more
the the brothers kind of working
together in this kind of bombastic yeah
set his way so this is obviously the
first uncharted game on the playstation
4 we're getting the nathan drake
collection as well what is it i mean the
classic question new hardware what is it
allowed you to do in this game that's
been impossible on the on the old I mean
just the size the sheer size the memory
that we have allows us to just make
everything bigger like this environment
is like it's just massive but and we're
just driving through it so fast it just
allows us to just the fact that we can
do that so seamlessly is it's a
testament to our programmers in our
artists to be able to do that and it
blows me away still when I even just
watch
it's yeah it's huge I'm the facial
animation so sorry you guys released a
few videos of nate's just like sure
expression yeah which is kind of it's
veering into uncanny valley territory
now a little bit it's just it looks so
great I mean how's the process changed
from uh real time is is a big deal for
us we've never had we've never had real
time cutscenes and uncharted before so
everything that we've done for the
cutscenes in previous games we have to
bring over make it real time and it
looks amazing this skin shaders and all
the little blend shapes and you oh not
about the tech but when you look at Nate
space in the beginning and lights
hitting up just right and you're like oh
that's all in its real time so you guys
I kind of like the flagship Sony
franchise is there a lot of pressure as
you kind of keep going and it gets more
successful I mean the pressure we put is
on ourselves yeah like within the studio
it's definitely the harshest critics and
like putting this demo together it's
every every day someone's coming over we
we watch it as a team we comment on
little things like oh there's this
little pop in this animation over here
or all this little thing that there's a
lod pop on this thing we need to fix it
so it's like constantly combing through
and making sure every little detail is
perfect and it's like if we can satisfy
ourselves and we're happy with we're
pointing out then I think we're gonna be
okay good I think you'll be fine I mean
like and I'm sure you have you
definitely have a vast legion of fans
any kind of special fan requests coming
into the game or are you just kind of
taking feedback on board and sing and
mulling it over I mean we have our we we
have our own we love the fans and
there's all you know every day Eddie 3
i'm watching fan reactions of the demo
and just seeing people get excited about
uncharted but you know we have you know
Neil Abruzzo directors and yeah they
have a vision and we you know we're
filling that vision and it's it's going
to be it's going to be awesome it's
Nathan Drake's final chapter so I think
fans are going to be happy
don't say that I know it it's kind of
it's spectacular and we're very excited
to see the game so let's don't fail
because I've been noticing some watching
the game play some little tweaks here
and there so i think the grappling
grappling hook can a rope thing oh yes
it's more and more than subtle it's it's
a bit for us anyway for for a game
designer it changes a lot of what you
can do how big the spaces need to be to
allow for a grappling hook it lets us
chained together things like you see in
the demo at the very end when nage jumps
out of the Jeep with the grapple hook
onto very Tiffany of 30 yeah you saw in
the PSX time we'll use in the rope a
little bit there's it kind of fulfills
all the different pillars of gameplay of
uncharted game using the exploration
puzzle-solving combat so that's kind of
what we try to do with all our mechanics
is make sure that they can overlap in
Lincoln ways so the vehicles another one
to where we're singing in a set piece
here but we're that were that's not the
first time you're gonna drive the
vehicle it's gonna be perfect we're
gonna make sure that the players is
comfortable with their mechanics before
we throw them into a set piece and you
know have get hunted down by the store
truck so I mean the Uncharted on pizza
obviously used quite a lot of the
touchpad a touchpad functionality we're
sure are we gonna be getting that legit
and the DualShock 4 uh we we love the
DualShock 4 it it's my favorite
controller for sure and yeah we're still
still figuring out what we can do with a
dual shock but I think we're gonna do
some cool stuff of it and of course it
wouldn't it wouldn't be current gen
video games without the 30 60 debate
that's still a thing that we're doing
apparently you guys sent targeting 60
but 30 is fine and I agree where you out
with that now yeah I mean if you look at
the demo and just how much is happening
on the screen kind of physics yeah it's
insane we want to turn it to look like
the best game we can possibly make so uh
there's no point making a 60 frame game
if it chugs to sub petty right hot it
solid frame rate ISM is important is the
most important thing that it's
consistent so yeah but in a multiplayer
we are targeting 60 and multiplayers
yeah so we know how how it feels on the
stick to have that for a multiplayer
game to have you know the response with
him so still targeting 60 in and
multiplayer so um stealth is also i mean
nate is kind of not he's all guns
blazing most the time but sometimes he
has to step back and try and sneak his
way through encounters is that changing
a little bit the way we're gonna
approach it in yeah we added we learned
a lot from the last of us in terms of AI
and it seemed to fit for uncharted two
to kind of expand drake's a stealth
moveset stealth mechanics a little bit
so again trying to give player more
options in all of our scenarios so you
saw in the PSX demo you can the AI has
the other kind of communicating with
each other you can hide in shrubbery we
call it stealth grass but it's not
really grass it's whatever there's lots
of different kinds of bit of toe pre
yeah so yeah you can hit crouch in grass
you can stealth guys you can engage in
combat and then disengage allow the guys
to lose you you can kind of sneak around
you can skip enemies in certain areas so
yeah it's a really excited it's for
uncharted two have so many options it's
like yes a dream when it came to sort of
not redesigning but you know adding in
more self mechanics which games we kind
of looking at which you know which
really is why I do I mean we don't
really look at I mean obviously we play
games and we love other games but it's
like for us we just kind of look in at
what we want to play and what you know
we feel like we're the experts of
uncharted so yes we're what what do we
want an uncharted what do we want to add
what do we want to what do we think is
an evolution so to us it's yet it's
really accentuating the fluidity adding
rope movement speed having every move be
just impactful in melee and vehicles for
the first time is it really like because
that is huge I mean it is a big thing to
put into a game and yes yeah well work
we've been working on vehicles for years
wow they are
which engine are you running in what's
that which engine is the game running
it's our naughty dog engine it's a
proprietary engine we've just kind of
evolved through the years and that we
built kind of from scratch and uncharted
one and every game we've iterated on and
like every game we just keep adding new
features different things and and ps4
the leap to ps4 was a big a big
challenge complete different
architectures so we had it took a while
and we're feel like we're pushing it
yeah really hard right now so are you
still finding things that you didn't
sort of know the engine could handle
could do well we find things a lot of
times we put stuff in the game and it's
terrible and then we work really really
hard to make it run in frame rate or to
add more things the idea for this demo
was like everything destructible in the
market like yeah if we want every as a
designer to say like oh we just want
everything to destroy yeah but to
actually make that a reality to have the
physics programmers and the artists and
everyone who's involved in making all
the little pieces break and being able
to have everything renderer on screen in
frame rate and making games is hard yeah
but I think that's what a lot of people
Tony appreciate maybe when games come
out as a glitch or something everyone
just goes thanks to Metacritic or
whatever um so what I mean so yo guys
gonna get again being crunch a little
bit while hopefully not crunch but you
can be very busy up until launch are we
gonna be seeing more of the game maybe a
PSX uh we're gonna be heads down working
on uncharted 4 to release it that's
pretty much the brighter right now is is
ship the game I I always get a boost of
energy hopefully the team gets a boost
energy team did an amazing job on this
on this demo and yeah we just need to
now follow through on that and just kind
of finish I make the rest of the game as
as awesome as what we've shown so far so
how important is it for you guys to be
able to show a live demo because I mean
it's it was it was like I was thinking
about this the other day because you
know the small mishap with the
controller functionality on the
on the live demo and I had a heart
attack and Bruce had a heart attack I
remember a few years ago I think it was
AG is war three when I said controller
just what it's called George is cake
yeah wait we're at least glad that it
wasn't the game swell it was like it was
a hardware something with the controller
so but I was think about this because
black people say you know why don't we
just do a video recorder live it's like
to make it real to make it playable it
forces us it's really for us it's like
the ultimate milestone deadline of it's
got to be playable on stage and because
you know if you have a video you can
take shortcuts and you're like oh it's
just a video will play it the perfect
way yeah and like record it or whatever
so it makes us yeah I have to hit our
frame rates and have to in it yeah it
and to see it and you know that it's
done and it's real it's awesome yeah I
mean I think that is the thing for the
game is the players themselves is that I
live play through it reinforces the fact
that the game is there like it it is
definitely coming it's not smoking
mirrors it's not gonna like last
guardian on us and vanish forever years
and then come back yeah you know like it
is that it's real it's real and it's
coming and it's real for us as
developers to like oh right we have got
to ship this game now but it's it's
gonna be fun yeah so I mean I wasn't
gonna say let's talk a little bit about
the story from what we've what we've
heard so captain Avery's treasure I mean
it is he based on kind of like real life
or is Henry Avery was a pirate in the
late 1600s did he would he had the
biggest pirate Hall of all time and kind
of Nate and his brother Sam are kind of
on the trail of this this ultimate Hall
of treasure so that's kind of what last
job exactly exactly it's the ultimate
pirate treasure yeah um and so where we
where are we gonna go something we've
seen such a great variety of
environments and uncharted before
obviously from snow desert cities jungle
are we getting to be visiting the same
kind of terrain I mean that's kind of a
one of my favorite things about on chart
is we get to kind of globe trot around
and see all these different lush
gorgeous environments
so yeah we're totally continuing that
even with in Madagascar we've got
Madagascar is kind of a geological
anomaly oh yeah you have these gorgeous
lush jungles you have amazing colorful
cities filled with people and we're
going to be going what kind of other
parts of the world too so I mean it's
not where you sort of just tied into you
know the real world parts of the story
with a captain Avery stuff when it comes
to choosing where you want to go or are
you free to sort of point pick a point
on a map it it's inspired by that for
sure uh the places where we go our kind
of following kind of Avery's life and
and death yeah so yeah it's a don't I
give too much away but it's a it's gonna
be cool so a lot of the all the temples
we've seen so far a very action-packed
and that's great but I am a big fan of
the puzzles oh yeah you know like you
know heading into an old decrepit too
much I guess if out what I mean I assume
is gonna be some more how have you guys
been designing for those uh puzzles are
hard yeah but yeah take away this
video's that games aha games are hard
game making games is really hard
uncharted 3 I think had some really
really great puzzles in it we know that
that's that's kind of a trope of
uncharted it's a it's a pillar of
Uncharted to have that kind of stuff and
absolutely we're gonna have puzzles and
now they have like new mechanics we're
going to see you know ropes use and
puzzles vehicle puzzles you know proper
solving stuff and then even just you
know in the traversal it's it's a
problem solving but yeah its terms of
like the classic uncharted temp the
temple puzzle kind of thing yeah
absolutely we're gonna have we're gonna
fans will be happy for [ __ ] out with the
extra like mo openness of the game is
that not more difficult to sort of rein
it in when it comes to your bigger
environments like yeah I mentioned with
the pacing before we have to because you
have you have to make sure that when we
open up the environment and allow the
player to play through kind of
in the difference may go explore that it
makes sense in the story to do that yeah
so we don't want you when you're oh my
god I got to get to sams like oh well
I'm gonna go play around with the I'm
gonna find treasures over here so it's
constantly a battle kind of on the game
design to like we want to give all these
choices and all these things but we have
to make sure that we get that roller
coaster that that push of the story and
I think we've done a pretty good job and
in our we have some big areas in this
game yeah and we definitely expand that
exploration for sure I mean cuz from my
memory I'm tronic net doesn't
necessarily because it was more linear
like it wasn't necessary to have a
prompt like on screen saying you need to
go this way but one something the last
was it really well is that when you're
in buildings the exit sign was always
still uh it was always still illuminated
so that's how I always found my way
through it I mean are you gonna tackle
on on chart for yeah I mean it's hard
again it's a it's one of the hardest
things that game design is to have it
let the player know where they have to
go and what they have to do it's like
kind of the number one rule so yeah when
you when you're like a big thing for nye
dog is is minimal HUD we don't want to
kind of interfere with a experience most
of the time in the demo you see no HUD
on the screen and yeah that's not fake
for the demo that's like everyone knows
on chart it's like that's the real
experience of playing so yeah it's it's
you know setting up goals like we have
in the cutscene there you see the tower
in the distance you kind of see that
tower throughout and you know that
downhill is the way to go so you're kind
of in the level design have to y'all
talk about a level design as yeah but uh
yeah it's it's one of the hardest things
for sure for a designer to make a level
to make uncharted levels in general it's
hard what comes first then the M so you
seen this like a broad outline of the
story maybe the key beats have been
pinned down but then you guys have to
obviously develop along at the same time
so how do you kind of design when you
don't really know the exact specific
specific parts so I mean we have the
story outline kind of beginning the end
of the game
am already when before we start laying
out levels but then we go to the
designer and the designer we it's kind
of like kind of like you said where
there's beats that we want to have
happen and then we live to the designer
to really own that and kind of fill in
the experience with with knowing where
you know guiding them with you know
where where our mechanics at at this
point in the game and what how can we
exploit them in new ways and then just
kind of hand it off to to it the
designer making that level and nurturing
their like abilities to in guiding so
it's it's a lot of fun yeah um so used
to be you mentioned with the jump from
ps3 to ps4 obviously a significant jump
in hardware capability what was the
trickiest bit to to figure out adapt for
I guess I mean with are things with the
PlayStation 4 that you didn't anticipate
like um I don't know it definitely gave
us more of everything yeah more memory
more more more more and then you're like
all more throw everything at it and then
you're like okay this is crazy and then
you still make it work anyway yeah the
programming team and I dog is is
ridiculous and I'm I'm consistently
blown away it's like I'm so spoiled as a
game designer to be able to go over and
be like ok we're here's the crazy thing
we want to do I know like that's crazy
crazy cat it will make it work it's my
favorite thing on my dog is you propose
a crazy idea like some insane chase down
a hill on the streets everything
destructible and they don't say no
they're like we'll make it work that's
awesome so this is what's why I love
coming to work every day ok I'm afraid
that's all we have time for thank you so
much for joining me really can't wait to
play the game next year thank you for
having me you make sure you stay to you
and hit a game squad because we have so
much more awesome stuff coming up so
make sure you don't go anywhere